ليبيا تتحول الى رقعه شطرنج بين ايادي قوى
اجنبيه بحسب معسكر الشرق الليبي والهدف هو
الفوز باتفاقيات استغلال مواردها الطبيعيه
وابرز اللاعبين على هذه الرقعه ابرز
لاعبين في الواقع ايطاليا وتركيا فبعد
تركيا جاء الدور الايطالي التي او جاء دور
ايطاليا التي وقعت اتفاقيه مع المؤسسه
الوطنيه للنفط الليبيه لانتاج واستغلال
الغاز وذلك في صفقه بلغت قيمتها 8 مليارات
دولار اتفاقيه تم توقيعها بين رئيسه
الوزراء الايطاليه
ورئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه عبد الحميد
دبي اتفاقيه تطرح علامات استفهام حول
طريقه التعامل بين ايطاليا وتركيا التي
سبق لها وان وقعت اتفاقيتين في مجال النفط
والغاز مع طرابلس لكن على ما يبدو فانا
انقره وروما متفقتان بخصوص تقاسم النفوذ
في مجال الطاقه في ليبيا وذلك نقلا عن
وزير الخارجيه الايطاليه انطونيو يعني
الاتفاقيه الايطاليه الليبيه تقتضي
بالاساس تطوير حقلي غاز قباله السواحل
الليبيه على امتداد ثلاث سنوات وهو ما
يختلف نسبيا عن الاتفاقيه الموقعه بين
طرابلس وانقره والتي كانت تسمح لتركيا
بالتنقيب عن النفط والغاز في المياه
الاقليميه الليبيه ورغم الاتفاقيات
العديده الموقعه بين تركيا وحكومه
الدبايبه في الاونه الاخيره الا ان
ايطاليا تبقى الشريك التجاري الاهم لليبيا
ولاسيه ما في مجال المحروقات حيث تعد
مجموعه الايطاليه اكبر شريك اجنبيه في
استخراج الغاز الطبيعي في ليبيا كما ان
الامدادات الليبيه تؤمن اكثر من ثلث
احتياجات استهلاك ايطالي
بيت فقيه عاديه جدا واذا تم اعتمادها من
قبل رئاسه الوزراء فهذا تعتبر اتفاقيه
تعتبر عقد رسمي وذلك وفق قانون رقم 24
لسنه 1970 اما ما يخص بالاتفاق السياسي في
طبعا ايطاليا الى مصالح في ليبيا من ناحيه
الهجره الاستثمارات
حوالي ايطاليا والمانيا تعيش حوالي 30%
على الطاقه الليبيه
ليس لديها يعني قرار او شخص يمثل الدوله
الليبيه بمعنى ان حكومات متعدده في في
ليبيا انا اعتقد ان الاتفاقيه هذه يعني مش
مصالح المواطن الليبي هذه الاتفاقيات همم
مصالح الشركات همم الاعتبارات فقط
سراج همم حدثت همم في الترسيم الحدود
البحريه مع تركيا
الموقعه بين همم ايطاليا وليبيا مع حكومه
غريبه بيقع الاشكال في حكومه دبي ذاتها
باعتبارها غير الشرعيه لا باس من توقيع
اتفاقيات في هذا التوقيت جديده خصوصا
ليبيا على همم طيره عقد كامل تشهد سرعات
سياسيه وضع امني اا متردي فالاقتصاد
بطبيعه اتحاد تاثر رفقه هذه همم المسارات
السياسيه والامنيه